[Music]
hi everyone welcome to Google Cloud next
and to this session why now is the right
time to migrate your apps to manage
databases on Google Cloud
my name is sujata mandawa and I am the
product management leader for cloud SQL
joining me later is Joseph zarelli
senior software engineer for Major
League Baseball
in this session we'll first talk about
the challenges with self-managing
databases we'll then discuss how Cloud
SQL can help you with your database
needs followed by a quick look at the
latest advances in Cloud SQL finally Joe
will share his MLB Journey with Cloud
SQL
let's get started
managing databases is hard
once you get the database provisioned
and configured you need to spend time
maintaining them keeping them up to date
on versions and patches you also need to
Monitor and troubleshoot any performance
issues that may arise
as your organization grows you need to
support new Integrations with
applications and analytic tools all the
while keeping costs under control
this operational burden leaves you with
fewer Cycles to spare on innovation
self-managing also means you need to
keep implementing security and data
protection measures to avoid data
breaches to protect your data you also
need to implement and maintain data
resiliency for business continuity
reasons you need to comply with
different regulations all this just adds
up to your responsibilities
we hear the same from you when you talk
about your challenges around scaling
your team to meet the demands of the
growing business and supporting analytic
Integrations
so how can Cloud SQL help
Cloud SQL reduces the operational toil
and frees you up to innovate faster with
Cloud SQL you can spin up database
instances quickly manage them very
easily and get critical insights into
the database performance with an out of
the box monitoring you can also leverage
first class Integrations with services
like bigquery gke that improves the
agility and data-driven innovation in
your organization
Cloud SQL reduces risk with Advanced
security controls data protection
capabilities that not only help you
secure your data but also keep up with
the ever-changing regulatory
requirements
Cloud SQL is a trusted integrated and
intelligently managed database services
for some of the most popular relational
databases in the world MySQL postgres
SQL Server
Cloud SQL is easy to set up operate and
scale with just a few clicks you can
create a highly available instance Auto
scale storage with replicas across the
region and have multi-regional backups
that can support today's Global
applications
Cloud SQL makes it easy for you to
control track and review data access
with tools like IM authentication
database audit access transparency and
more
with an API first approach Cloud SQL
simplifies deployment and configuration
at scale the application-centric
observability helps with troubleshooting
and performance tuning of your
application it is no wonder that 90 of
Google Cloud's top 100 customers use
cloud SQL some of the biggest
organizations in the world are actively
using and benefiting from these
capabilities
in a recent research study IDC concluded
that with Cloud SQL you get a whopping
246 percent return on investment
compared to self-managed on-prem
databases it is 96 faster to create and
deploy a new database instance with
Cloud SQL
as you can see it's used by tens of
thousands of customers across Industries
across the world ranging from e-commerce
to supply chain to automobile
manufacturing here are some of them
talking about how Cloud SQL enables them
to provide a better customer experience
better customer outcomes by spending
less time on managing and scaling the
infrastructure
looking ahead what's coming up on cloud
SQL let's talk about some of our recent
Investments well our Focus has been on
providing Enterprise capabilities that
make it easier to lift and shift your
databases to Cloud SQL we've also been
investing in reducing the operational
overhead that's typically taken for
granted in a self-managed world
let's start with SQL Server
with SQL Server you can create read
replicas where your read workload is
either the same region or of as your
priority instance or a different region
or both we've also made it easier for
you to replicate your SQL Server data to
an external instance with the recently
learned SQL Server as a publisher
feature with transactional replication
running under the hood SQL Server as a
publisher gives you the flexibility to
use standard edition to replicate data
to external environments for additional
processing and redundancy a new addition
to SQL servers capabilities is database
auditing which allows you to monitor
database changes like data inserts and
table deletions
finally SQL Server also now offers major
version upgrades in place major version
upgrades and Edition upgrades making it
easier for you to stay up to date with
the newest version and unlock the
capabilities that higher editions offer
now continuing on the track of major
version upgrades we now have this
feature GA in MySQL and public preview
in postgres the ability to preserve the
IP addresses users and settings on the
upgraded instance makes it makes what is
a lengthy and tedious task fast and
extremely simple
preparing for Dr preparing for Dr with a
low RTO is now easier than ever with
Cloud SQL you can now enable ha for any
read replica and when promoted it
becomes a standalone instance with ha
without any additional configuration
this dramatically reduces RTO with the
Improvement especially noticeable for
large database instances we also
recently launched cascading replicas
this makes it easy to mirror the primary
reason topology into a Dr region
simplifying Dr while reducing
replication load on the primary
now let's talk about data protection we
recently launched two new features to
help you better protect your data with
password policy you can enforce policies
for password length complexity rotation
and more making it easier to adhere to
compliance requirements for local users
with delete protection you can now
Safeguard your Cloud SQL instances from
accidental deletion and avoid the
anxiety that follows in restoring it
now let's switch gears a little bit and
talk about observability insights
recommenders and more query insights
helps you detect diagnose and prevent
query performance problems for cloud SQL
databases supports intuitive monitoring
provides diagnostic information that
goes beyond detection it actually helps
your root cause the performance problem
you can monitor performance at an
application Level and Trace the source
of the problematic query across the
application stack today insights is
available on postgres MySQL just run GA
and alloy DB is in preview
system insights system insights provides
an overall dashboard for monitoring the
health of the database can help diagnose
and identify issues to prevent incidents
and improve performance you can see the
current resource usage but also how
frequently you're approaching resource
saturation limits making problem
detection extremely easy
system insights is available today in
preview mode for both postgres and alloy
DB
goal of observability is about helping
you identify the problem as soon as it
happens and sometimes even before it
happens to quickly get value out of the
growing database Telemetry we've
introduced proactive recommendations
powered by active assist these new
intelligent recommendations help you
detect and right size over provision
instances and idle Cloud SQL instances
these features are in GA and some of our
customers have gained up to 20 cost
savings just by using these
recommendations
let's move on to security recommenders
with this feature you get continuous
detection of security vulnerabilities
checks for risk fees risky security
configurations that helps you protect
your data you can get recommendations on
unencrypted connections broad public IP
access and more along with easy to
follow steps to resolve the
configuration issues finally performance
recommenders performance recommenders
helps you adopt best practices for
configuring Cloud SQL database instances
these recommenders identify and help you
resolve common misconfigurations that
increase the risk of performance
degradation downtime or being out of
compliance with Cloud sql's operational
guidelines we are excited to announce
the preview of security and performance
recommenders for cloud SQL at Google
Cloud next
given our commitment to Open Standards
we are merging SQL comment commenter and
open source object relational mapping
orm library with open Telemetry and open
source observability framework I'm happy
to share that we just completed the
merge of our first python library with
open telemetry we're really excited
about these new Cloud SQL capabilities
and invite all of you to try them out
with that I would like to welcome Joe to
share his Cloud SQL experience with us
Hey Joe welcome to the Google Cloud next
as well as this session
thanks jatha yeah I'm excited to be here
awesome so whenever I think of MLB I
think of the baseball games I've been to
I've watched the Giants the A's the
White Sox many more games because I have
a family of crazy about sports
for folks that are not familiar with
baseball can you give us an overview of
MLB and also along with that your
challenges with managing on-prem
databases yeah absolutely
um yeah first awesome to hear that
you're a baseball fan uh that's always
great to hear and yeah for those
non-baseball fans out there who may not
know what MLB is we are the professional
sports organization behind the highest
level of competitive baseball in the
world uh we featured some of the
greatest athletes of all time like Babe
Ruth and Jackie Robinson all the way up
to present day Superstars like Aaron
judge and shohei Otani
um so for those of you who are familiar
with baseball when you think of MLB you
probably think of players like those or
your favorite team but what you may not
realize is how much technology we have
behind the scenes that's so vital to the
state of the sport today things like the
MLB TV streaming service to give fans
access to watch all the games all the
on-field technology we use to capture
stats data that we provide to fans and
even the software systems we build to
assist with league and front office
operations and one of those systems
known as ebis which runs the live MLB
draft and allows team front offices to
submit player transactions like trades
and free agency signings was previously
using Legacy Enterprise database hosted
on-premises which caused a lot of pain
points for our engineering team
so firstly we really didn't have a lot
of In-House expertise in the Legacy
database that we were using and we had a
very small team just two people who need
to go through whenever we needed any
kind of devops work done or maintenance
work so things like backing up the
database or restoring and even stuff
like debugging Deadlocks was really
challenging for us
also because we're on a paid licensed
Enterprise database we were limited to
the by the number of licenses we had so
that really restricted our development
team because we could only have a
certain number of environments and we
only had one instance per environment
and so all of our read and write
workflows would go through that same
instance and because we're putting so
much load on it we were always worried
that our database would experience the
greater performance especially during
big events like the live televised MLB
draft and if things were to go wrong
we'd have to pause the draft to the left
teams more time to pick their players
which would be really stressful
yeah and we don't want that to happen
definitely so thank you for that
introduction and walking us of course
through all your challenges so what made
you choose Cloud SQL yes so back a few
years ago um MLB chose to switch to
Google Cloud platform as its cloud
computing provider uh so we're already
in the process of moving our
applications and services to a lot of
other gcp products like kubernetes
engine Pub sub Cloud functions and some
of our newer products were even already
using Cloud SQL in addition to that we
were looking to standardize our
relational database management system
around postgres company-wide so that we
could build in-house expertise around a
single database instead of needing our
rather small engineering team to be
proficient across many different
databases
um so we knew we wanted to move to
postgres and we were already running
mostly everything in gcp so naturally we
looked at Cloud SQL and we saw that
supported all the database flags that we
needed and also we thought that could
solve a lot of our problems around High
availability and automation
um so yeah for high availability uh all
we had to do was enable Cloud sql's High
availability feature which was just a
simple configuration update and right
away we had protection against Regional
outages as for automation at MLB we use
terraform to provision and manage our
infrastructure and Google provides
terraform modules for cloud SQL so we
were able to create new instances with
just a few lines of terraform code and
we could spin them up in minutes with
the exact configuration we wanted
um we also leverage Google class apis to
create an automated backup restore
process taking that from what used to be
a four hour manual process to a
20-minute automated workflow which
allows us to easily replicate production
issues and fix them as quickly as
possible
and probably the biggest win for us was
that we could finally offload some of
our read-only workflows by creating read
replicas and again all this was was a
couple lines of terraform code and we
now have all of our reporting servers
and our read-only API servers running
against the replicas instead of against
the main DB which has helped us
drastically improve our database
performance so this was actually the
first year running the MLB draft on
cloud SQL and because of all these
improvements we were able to make we
were able to go into draft day with a
ton of confidence that our systems work
properly and our fans could just enjoy
the broadcast without interruption and
players are waiting to be selected can
enjoy one of the biggest moments in
their life without the suspense of our
system regression
awesome that is so great to hear I'm
sure our product and Engineering teams
will be excited to hear that
um that you've been able to overcome
these challenges with Cloud SQL so now
that you're successfully running and
scaling with Cloud SQL what's next
yes so there's a ton of great new
features for cloud SQL that we're
looking to incorporate into our
day-to-day operations
um we're already using query insights to
identify our slowest queries or our big
Sluggers to make a bad baseball pun
which allows us to be proactive about
our performance issues and address them
before users report them we're also
really excited to start using system
insights and plan on using it as our
main monitoring tool in the upcoming
postseason and off season events and
also now that we have this ability to
create new database instances left and
right it's important to keep our costs
down and with the cost recommended or
Tool uh let us know if we have any
oversized or idle instances and give us
recommendations on how to appropriately
size them so we can keep our operational
costs down and the lead can invest more
in what's really important Fan
Experience and growing the game in
baseball
awesome yes and given these
macroeconomic conditions and all the
more importance so thank you Joe for
sharing your experiences with Cloud SQL
and looking forward to continuing this
incredible partnership yeah likewise
suggested thank you thank you
awesome with that I'd like to invite you
to start your migration Journey with
Cloud SQL today here are some resources
to help you get started thank you for
joining us with this session and have a
great Cloud next 2022.
[Music]